I'm not saying inappropriate things
haven't happened
um you know I'm straight but like I've
had
um
I've had like encounter not encounters
but like
um I did I did have a friend who um
it's almost like when you meet somebody
there and you've met them like
naked then
you can continue but it's like bringing
somebody from I don't know normal life
into that environment is always so
difficult so
um when I had this friend over and we
were just smoking I just answered the
door I wasn't you know wearing anything
and
um
and you know it was
it's kind of fun in games and um
you know I I did get like erect like I
remember I was like we you know we were
smoking